Remember that the complex number a plus bi can be graphed on this coordinate
plane as the point a,b. So, we need to figure out how each of these points is
written in this form, or what a and b are each equal to. The number 7 is equal
to 7 plus 0i, if you want to write it like this. So it should be the point 7,0,
which is c over here. This makes sense. This is a real number, so it's written
strictly along the real axis. A similar thing happens for negative 7i, which is
just an imaginary number. Here, a is equal to 0 since there's no real part to
this number, so its coordinates should be 0, negative 7, which is this point e.
Now, negative 7 plus 7i is already written in a plus bi form or it's already
recognizably written that way. So, its coordinates are negative 7, 7, which is
point h.